spider-man no way home is one of the
mcu's biggest successes both in terms of
critical response and box office numbers
while the world is still reeling from
the movie's shock cameos there were
plenty of monumental moments in the film
that didn't include you know who of
course aunt may's death is easily no way
home's most devastating moment but the
ending wasn't an easy pill to swallow
either after dr strange performs the
spell that makes the world forget peter
parker mj and ned's memories are wiped
and peter chooses not to tell them about
their past together at the end of the
movie fans are left wondering if mj and
ned will ever remember who peter really
is of course many people will be holding
out hope that mj and ned are going to
remember peter as they once did and if
that's the case it's bound to occur in a
future spider-man movie but how could it
actually happen well sony producer amy
pascal recently confirmed to fandango
that the studios are getting ready to
make the next spider-man film she also
noted that sony and marvel are looking
at doing three more films so peter
parker will have plenty of time to
revert mj and ned to their old selves
obviously any ideas about how this will
go down are bound to be purely
speculative in nature luckily there are
probably an infinite amount of ways in
which mj and ned might remember peter
especially now that the multiverse has
been fully unleashed the simplest way
however would be to have dr strange
perform another spell naturally strange
would need some convincing since steven
also doesn't remember peter but you
could argue that it wouldn't be too hard
for peter to convince him that they have
a history if the youngster just
explained some of the events that
occurred on titan during avengers
infinity war only the heroes who were
there on titan could possibly know what
happened and strange would quickly
accept the possibility his memory has
been tampered with
i'm peter by the way doctor strange oh
using their made up names um
i'm spider-man then
after all no way home makes clear that
he has performed the spell before so
it's not like the mind erasing trick
would seem unusual to him as simple as
this idea is that's the problem it's a
little too simple if ned and mj's
memories are to be restored it'll likely
be in a more dramatic fashion than
simply asking strange to make things
right with so many projects in the works
in the mcu and dozens of characters
spread throughout them it's not a
far-fetched idea to think someone else
outside of the spider-man films can help
with ned and mj's amnesia wanda maximoff
is now more powerful than ever as the
scarlet witch and we know she's dabbled
in mind control on occasion wanda is a
trickier player than strange however and
you wouldn't want her putting illusions
into ned and mj's heads still maybe
there's a more sensitive tweak to her
powers via which she can undo strange's
spell in this case though there would
have to be some reason for peter and
wanda to meet up while elizabeth olsen
is set to appear in dr strange in the
multiverse of madness it seems unlikely
that holland will make a cameo and who
knows what the mcu has in store for
wanda after that movie's released one
character who is rumored to show up in
the second doctor strange flick is
charles xavier professor x knows a thing
or two about mind control and if he
effectively becomes canon in the mcu he
might be someone whose powers are
available to peter with all the mind
powers in his arsenal it's almost a
guarantee that professor x could
retrieve erased memories from a subject
especially when they live on in someone
else that of course is assuming that
xavier even makes it out of multiverse
of madness there are plenty of other
characters who could also help in the
quest to revert the memories of peter's
friends some of whom we haven't even met
yet whoever it might be who lights the
spark here's hoping it happens soon
because what is the mcu spider-man
without his ned and mj check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you